if you're not crushing it right now as
an entrepreneur you suck you got your
prospective happy don't you want to be
happy Gary he's here right now
[Applause]
hello hello hello
bid summit thanks for having me so just
having a great sense of like the way
people have been tweeting about the
event and a good understanding of who's
in the room I actually want to do quite
a bit of Q&A today so before I go any
further you guys said you had runners I
just want to get a sense like where are
the runners and like I might go into it
like 10 or 15 minutes in so that summit
crew be ready for me because I'm about
to go into it and so just raise your
hand if you have a question when I open
that up and I and I want to go questions
because ultimately what I think is super
important about when you produce content
or when you speak I think the biggest
actually is a great starting point I
genuinely believe that the far majority
of this room is not achieving what they
want to achieve if they're not so if
you're sitting here and you haven't
amassed enough audience or revenue or
whatever might be running through your
mind the biggest thing that I've seen
over the last 12 years that I've deeply
been paying attention to creators and
just to give people context here it was
great to see Rob sandy the CEO and
founder of vid IQ who was also the CEO
and founder of a company called bid ler
which was the platform that I switched
my wine show from because I started a
wine show on YouTube on February 21st
2006 less than one year after YouTube
came out 99 percent of the videos on
YouTube when I started were
daf content from television or these
very quick you know less than a minute
kind of funny clips of like mentos in a
coke bottle or things of that nature i
sat down and did a twenty five minutes
show it was mainly kids and tech nerds I
did a twenty five minutes show on wine
and me tasting wine and literally for
the first 18 months barely anybody
watched it and and so it's interesting
for me to like be you know at this at
this event knowing there's just so many
people that are creating but the thing
that no question to me is a great
starting point is I am blown away how
many creators spend all their time being
selfish mentally like 99% of the emails
and DMS and conversations I have in
conferences like this are predicated on
how to start with how do i how do I get
more subscribers how do I get more
engagement how do I get more money from
brands how do I quit my job and do this
full time how do i how do i how do i so
i will tell you without knowing most of
you in any shape or form i still will
default into that ninety five percent of
the people in this room will not get to
where they want to get to because their
entire [ __ ] filter on everything
they're doing is 100% selfish and the
only way to actually amass victory in
this game where as amazing it is that we
live in the day and age now where you
can be a creator and like just live your
life and love what you do and make a
living the equal problem is anybody can
do it which creates a very fun the
economy of supply and demand this is a
simple game of supply and demand
anybody tomorrow can be a Slimer or a
travel vlogger or a business expert or a
[ __ ] entrepreneur right anybody can
do that the problem for everybody here
is anybody can do that and then who's
gonna get people's attention the people
that are gonna get people's attention
fall into a very basic bucket number one
the second biggest vulnerability for the
creators in this room and the people at
home that will
this is a it's III B it's just not the
truth for me one of the most interesting
things that I watch every day in this
space is people think that fake it till
you make it is still real there are so
many people posing it because they feel
like they have to inflate their
backstory or what they're capable of or
the advice that they're giving to
breakout yet that is the exact same
reason that they won't break out to me
everybody who's trying to be a life
coach or expert or you know an
entrepreneurial expert like the amount
of people that are entrepreneurial
experts but have never built an
entrepreneurial thing look I wish I
could be a quarterback of an NFL team
but like I can't and all of you can see
that and it's proven unfortunately with
entrepreneurship it's not proven you can
just put it in your Instagram profile
and thus you are the big advantage that
everybody in here like myself that's
over 40 has is we've lived through an
economic meltdown we've lived through
everything yeah we lived through I mean
there was one a no one and oh seven so
we got to quick like and then if you're
old enough you've got 92 and like you
know 17 I mean that was the worst like
Jimmy Carter [ __ ] it up guys
and so we've lived through it thus we
anticipate it in a different way that if
you're under 32 you can't because if
you've only lived life professionally in
an environment where the economy has
been flourishing you don't realize what
happens which is literally tomorrow
morning you can wake up and we can have
a Bear Stearns some sort of event that
completely starts the collapse of the
economy and all of a sudden the DMS from
a detox tea or from Pepsi or coach stop
and if your entire money is coming from
your audience that buys 22 let me tell
you what stops when the economy
collapses people don't just want to buy
a 22 dollar t-shirt that has a funny
saying on it big brands don't want to
pour money because they don't have it
into the market and so what I wear I'm
really
going with this as a couple things
context is what drives a lot of success
when you read all your comments for all
your content you get context from your
audience and it helps you think about
the next place you can go with your
storytelling instead of you just being
creative and guessing but you have to
put in the work to read the comments
context in understanding what's
happening right now in the global
economy this is all growing but it's
growing during a time of frothy massive
economic growth so if you're sitting
here and your strategy is I'm gonna get
off my job and I'm gonna get into this
or I'm now making 80k a year doing this
but I'm about to go to a half a million
you have to contextualize the moment
we're in I tell entrepreneurs all the
time and I don't want to razz here but I
want everybody wrap their head around it
if you're not crushing it right now as
an entrepreneur you suck this is the
easiest era ever to be winning and you
have to contextualize that so a couple
things you might just start now and
you're only three months in you didn't
have time to crush it but [ __ ] if you've
been trying to do it as an entrepreneur
for the last five and a half years and
it's not clicking you need to work for
somebody you want to know what most
people's vulnerability is I the reason I
always win every time I enter something
else it's what can I do for you and not
the person that has 11 million just the
person that's right next to me because
karma and doing the right thing and
kindness and being a [ __ ] human
always wins in the end
always
it does it does because because what you
don't know is the person next to you may
have 48 subscribers but his aunt run
[ __ ] and everybody here's jockeying and
overthinking and politicking in their
head all from a selfish place and all
the magics sitting in the doing the
right thing saying hello being patient
but most of all the thing that will
speed you up in the thing that you want
to accomplish no question is you've got
to become religious about your audience
like you have to become religious about
your audience like guys honestly
straight up if you're sitting in the
crowd right now it's unacceptable for
you not to reply to the comments you get
on your content I don't know how
honestly like [ __ ] it like I'm just
gonna go that literal with it I don't
like to do definitive things because
that's just not how life is but I'm just
comfortable going there it is actually
fundamentally grossly negligent and
unacceptable for you to be in a place
where you do not reply with a thank you
or a heart or a meaningful you read it
and you meaningfully wrote something
back to every single comment you have
right now in whatever limited that is
because those seven people are
disproportionately the reason you're
gonna get 17 and yet you're so worried
about getting the next 10 that don't
know you you're giving no [ __ ] love
to the seven that decided to watch your
horseshit my favorite people here are
the ones like people don't get me yet
I'm too over the top for them I'm too
futuristic people don't understand me
yet they understand you they think you
suck like like I love that [ __ ] like
Gary I'm coming from a totally different
angle no you're not angel you actually
just suck people wanna pee are
themselves to not address their
insecurities to me the market is right
if you if you're not winning right now
it means you're losing it means the
market doesn't like what you're putting
out now you have a question to ask
yourself are you gonna do something that
you think the markets gonna like cuz you
want that short term but it's not your
authentic self or are you gonna stay the
course of what you do and see how it
plays out for me the second one's
clearly amazing here's why my big
problem right now with this
space is that everybody's trying to make
a million dollars a year I'm trying to
get people to understand that if you're
making fifty three thousand a year or
ninety two or whatever it may be doing
something you hate wouldn't it be
awesome if you can make that same exact
number just making videos about star
Trak or [ __ ] supreme clothes or like
making yogurt right like to me what has
really bothered me about this space is I
don't think people realize the long tail
of this space is the special thing of
this whole game the to me the person
here who's making 114 thousand a year
doesn't like it super passionate about
streetwear and she or he is trying to
make their content online I'm always
trying to convince them like yo you're
making 114 can you look at what you're
spending can you live a little more
humbly so actually you only need 82
because if you only need 82 you can get
faster to getting happy and once you get
on the game to making 82 in ads and
brand deals you'll get to 114 in a
second cuz now you're gonna full-time
energy will open it up we have a very
big problem that we're creating
infrastructure costs around ourselves
there's a lot of people here who are
like hiring post-production people and a
PR person and [ __ ] building out a
team and they've got no money coming in
to look the part the market decides not
your self esteem coach you know what I
mean the market if you're so good and
you're worth $500 an hour as a designer
or an editor that means people are
actively paying you and if you're not
living in an ivory tower in your own
[ __ ] head that you're worth 500 bucks
is why 99% of people lose they buy [ __ ]
they don't need which that makes them
stuck in their business it's a [ __ ]
evil game it like having like you see me
talking a lot about move back home do
this stuff I'm doing it because moving
into your parent in law's basement as a
man takes a level of humility and
confidence that most people don't roll
with but it's gonna be the single reason
how old are you 38 it's gonna be the
single reason the core foundational
reason that you're gonna be happy for
the next 70 years
people are literally not willing to take
one step backwards to be happy in
perpetuity cuz they're worried their
buddies from high school on Facebook are
gonna make a snarky comment of them
living in their in-laws basement I
[ __ ] [ __ ] go ahead
no and I mean that's where I'm at I I
have an MBA
I'm a retired Marine I'm like what are
people gonna think and at some point I
was just like forget it it just doesn't
matter bro yeah like like they're not
living your life so you're right so you
always say people offer you lunch or
coffee or like there's value in that for
me yeah I mean you know I don't like
when people do it like there I hate I
hate the people at this point still
think they can trick me like I'm
disrespected by their audacity that
they're fooling me with their big
upfront like Gary I'm gonna do a huge
favor I'm gonna pick you up at the
airport and get you cozily to your
[ __ ] hotel I'm like dick I'm tired I
don't need to [ __ ] give you advice
for 40 minutes after I land up a seven
hour flight to go into my hotel room so
I don't know it's not that it's not
worth it it's when I hate when people
posture and pose it as they're giving me
something it's far more likely when they
just ask authentically
[Music]